so here's here's the way this works now
I want you to have a look at this for a
second and you remember how I told you
in integration of my parts it's not as
simple as just a rule because you have
to make some kind of choice okay now I
want to choosing you and I want to
choose a DV DX what's guiding that
choice why do I choose one to be one
yeah that's right what I'm looking for
in particular
yeah it's that green arrow through the
green arrow right if you don't agree pin
get one so you can have a green arrow to
Victorian the same things the green
arrow leaks v and do you right and if
the integral of VDU is difficult that
sort of suggests to you maybe I've made
the wrong choice now I want you to watch
for this okay let's have a look here
we're going to do it twice okay cuz I'm
gonna try it you all this DVD here and
then we're trying to get it and see what
happens if you give it okay so option
one let's do this one in red option one
I'm just going to use the order that's
there let me call this one you and this
one thing okay
so if I say DV if I say U is equal to e
to the negative X right and I say that
there for beads I've got a derivative
over here that means this has to be cos
x what's the integral of cos x mr.
Simonds okay so you think okay remember
I was looking for that green arrow right
so you look at this and you think the
integral of VDU I don't know what to do
with that either the negative X sine X
that looks to me like it's just as bad
as the problem I started with so I look
at that thing okay let's just put it to
one side for the moment try the other
option so if I put cos x up here the
derivative is negative sine X that means
I have no choice but to make this our
age and the negative x what's the
integral I'm gonna give it yeah good you
are and then you like way okay this
doesn't look good
promisee because what I've got here I
mean I know the signs are different
because we chose in a different water
but you have something which is
basically the same integral do you
notice that e to the negative X sine X
actually no sorry the st. the signs on
same way you've got I know I'll rise
like the first up you got double
negative here okay
in other words whichever choice you make
for u and DV you seem to end up in this
insoluble position okay
but it's not in solvable okay what I
want you to notice is that when you're
working with trig derivatives okay sine
and cosine they kind of flip back and
forth between one number there is a sine
of 1/4 because it goes from sine to
cosine to negative sign to negative
cosine which comes back to Sun right so
it goes around but those science sort of
signs the pluses are the widest is I
could account for them so he's sort of
gonna do I'm gonna play use a bit of an
algebraic trick I'm gonna call this
integral I'm gonna give it a name
usually it doesn't matter that we give
it a name but this will just make one of
that to do easier to work with so I'm
gonna call this capital I and that'll
help us with recurrence relations next
time okay if I call this integral by as
you can see it doesn't matter I actually
took the blue option first but we'll get
the same thing either way so I'm gonna
go at UV which is this
there's UV takeaway what does
integrating my plants Tommy this is the
integral of V do you do you see that
okay so because I got my double
negatives in there this is gonna look
like so okay so fast very good now when
I look at this I think okay what do I do
with this and the answer for me is will
that be on the right hand side if I got
that as my first question I try that by
integration by parts okay
now that should make you a little bit
suspicious because you might think well
hold on oh they're just going to sort of
end up going round and round in circles
and the beautiful answer is if you keep
a sort of whole movies you don't go
around remember circles
watch what happens let's do integration
by parts all of this guy right you do
you in yes
devio DX and V okay which one would you
pick now what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually gonna leave those yeah okay I'm
going to do this in a way that mirrors
the way I did it the first time right
because I'm going to get a result which
is Chris symmetrical from what I got
here okay so if I call this one side
that gives me a derivative yep and here
I've gotta get okay now this looks weird
because when you draw your green arrow
you like wait a second wait a second
that was the original question was it
not so let's see what happens when we do
this I've got this original UV there
sitting at the front takeaway and the
integration we cut begins again so I
have a new UV right here it is that make
sense so I've got negative e to the
negative X sine X is the new UV takeaway
YouTube will all feed to you
yep which in this case it is negative
you didn't know you knew X cos x DX from
is packet now usually it's a bad sign if
you try to approach a question and then
you end up with something that ends up
similar to the original question in your
answer okay but here it's exactly what I
want because what what happens where the
signs are fault okay let's just get rid
of this too many negatives lying around
in movement it's a bit confused so here
I've got a double negative Y AB so
that's plus and then here I've got one
two three negatives right so this comes
up as one name now I could then write it
to rule of u- x cos x DX the right the
beginning I gave that a label I called
it by the interval okay now what's
beautiful about this is even though
there's eyes on both sides that's okay
this is just integration of solving for
I know time so I'm going to add a
Riverside Schmitz now there's two of
them
while of that I'm going to factor
outside of - I'm going to factor a bit
easier than making an X because that's
both of them and I might as well put it
in a more useful order like that okay
and now if what I want is actually just
I I'm just gonna divide and I actually
should have added a seat here because
that's where I actually integrated now
what's really nice about this is that
again it's like really is that what you
would have expected and the answer is
well if you just go ahead and verify
okay there is what I got
right and you just have to use chain
rule here and it just kind of
beautifully pans out okay so that was a
bit of an unexpected side effect that
when you do integration by parts
something that it's sort of hands to you
ends up also the you to be done by
integration by parts and recurrence
relations like I said it sort of pushes
that to another degree but we'll see
that later on okay so do not lose heart
remember I said to you choose your you
and your DB on the basis of this okay
but just because it looks awful
doesn't mean you're completely you know
up the creek without a paddle this we
might still be able to work with it
especially when you got trickier right
they're going to flip back and forth and
you're gonna get the situation
frequently okay